pour la communication de la Maison
Blanche il s'agit désormais quasiment
d'un rendez-vous hebdomadaire mais cette
fois comme pour encourager le progrès de
l'armée ukrainienne sur le terrain Joe
Biden a souhaité communiquer le détail
de ses aides directement à son homologue
volo dimirzelinski des lance-roquettes
multiples imars les fameux les munitions
qui les accompagnent des canons de 155
et des milliers d'obus à guidage GPS
c'est munitions qui font au moment même
où nous parlons des ravages par des tirs
de contrebatrie toujours plus précis sur
les positions russes en tout cas en
croire les communications interceptées
dans les rangs de l'armée russe par les
grandes oreilles du Pentagone un
pentagone qui stimule jour après jour
les industriels de l'armement américain
et leur sous-traitants étrangers pour
déstocker les munitions légères
compatibles avec les armes parfois
anciennes de l'armée régulière
ukrainienne car cette guerre est une
bataille de stocks les stocks de l'armée
russe datant parfois du pacte de
Varsovie contre les stocks des nations
essentiellement
occidentales qui ont choisi de soutenir
l'effort de guerre
ukrainien durant ces conférences de
presse généreuses en information
tactique le Pentagone confirme que
l'armée russe recule et qu'il est
essentiel que la progression ukrainienne
se confirme avant d'une part l'arrivée
des pluies de l'hiver et d'autre part
avant l'arrivée de 200 000 réservistes
rassemblés par la mobilisation partielle
décrétée par le Kremlin car si désormais
l'Ukraine devait se retrouver dans les
prochaines semaines en infériorité
numérique face à la Russie il
deviendrait alors vital de compenser ce
déséquilibre par un armement toujours
plus complet plus performant plus précis